let's get more detail on what's going on
and all the developments in ukraine
today you can see our defense analyst dr
alex walmsley is here good to see you
again let's talk obviously first about
lissy shanks just how significant is
that capture if indeed the russians are
to be believed
yes if this is confirmed it's a very
strategic and important moment for
russia because it does mean that they
will have consolidated their hold on the
whole of the luhansk region
liciansk is a city that was before the
war about 95 000 people um and there is
still fierce fighting we understand
going on in the city but it is now
encircled by russians even though the
ukrainians are holding out but one of
the original goals in fact the whole
pretext for the invasion on the 24th of
february was said russia to liberate
the donbass region the self-proclaimed
republics of luhansk and donetsk
from the grip of ukrainian nazism and
fascism so this would this would
consolidate this part of the territory
and allow russia to focus on the
southern donetsk region where they don't
as you can see from this map have full
control and of course it has to be said
doesn't it that uh even the ukrainians
had said that the city was close to
collapse so we're waiting for uh for
their version of what's happened what
about the wider
war itself now is all the fighting
really confined to this region well this
is where the fiercest fighting is taking
place but we are seeing some gains and
losses on both sides along the southern
flank
where you'll remember the fighting
around mario paul
and as the russians push forward to
odessa
what we're seeing is that periodically
the ukrainians demonstrate that they can
hit russian targets inside the russian
border with their own missiles that are
being supplied from the west but
likewise the russians can hit ukrainian
targets very far in the west such as
kiev or odessa
with their long-range artillery just
very quickly the scenes we've seen in
lissy
similar in a way to what what happened
in mario paul is that right very much so
the the russian tactic now there's
they've abandoned all pretext of
strategic targeting it is artillery
bombardment until there really isn't
much left of the city at all and then
the russian forces can enter but but to
a city of rubble
all right alex thanks a lot